entschuldigung noch ein eis fuß musik
apfel kiwi dazu kleine und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut ich habe
heute diese müsste aufhalten man sehen
kann ist wichtig was meine harmlos ist
ich habe euch wichtig so ein tag wo ich
absolut unzufrieden mit meinen haben
sind aber ich hatte auch echt schon
lange keine mütze mehr auf deswegen
leute was machen heute mir hast
wahrscheinlich am titel schon gelesen
diese frage die habe ich irgendwie immer
im wissen was machen wir denn heute
obwohl das eigentlich jeder im titel
direkt liest ihr klickt ihr auch nur
deswegen auf das video weil es
wahrscheinlich wissen wollt mir wurde
nämlich gestern zufällig das video
vorgeschlagen was ich vor eineinhalb
jahren mal gedreht hat mcdonald's
produkte die fast niemand kennt so der
zeit habe ich viele fastfood videos
gemacht und alles mögliche ausprobiert
und da waren sie bei mcdonald's sonntag
produkte bei die habe ich vorher noch
nie gesehen und ich wusste auch gar
nicht dass es sie gibt und deswegen
dachte ich dass die meisten von euch die
wahrscheinlich auch nicht kennen und da
ist dann halt dieses video entstanden
ich habe gestern gesehen bin mal auf die
mcdonald's page gegangen um zu gucken ob
es eventuell wieder neue produkte gibt
die halt ebenfalls die meisten leute
nicht kennen also zur erklärung ich sehe
dass in diesen videos dann so wenn ich
jetzt dieses produkt schon ich kenne
obwohl ich mich eigentlich ganz gut
damit auskennen denke ich mal besser als
die meisten von euch auch nicht kennen
deswegen steht dem titel hat fast
niemand das hier ist das video was ich
vor eineinhalb jahren hochgeladen habe
und ich hatte gestern halt irgendwie mal
wieder bock auf so ein video so was halt
einfach mal wieder zu machen weil es an
sich immer ganz unterhaltsam ist auch
für mich und natürlich lecker und ich
habe so viele sachen gesehen von denen
ich wirklich von denen habe ich noch nie
was gehört die meisten sachen davon sind
jetzt auch neu zum sommer rausgekommen
wie zum beispiel dieses hier ich weiß
gar nicht was das sein soll ob man das
wirklich in seinem glas bekommt aber
generell ist übrigens kein mcdonald's
player also ich mache das alles
freiwillig wenn wir uns hier mal die
produkte anschauen diese des neckars
sind zwar auch relativ neu die sehe ich
jetzt aber nicht mehr als besonders an
dieser vegan burger tsd mich auch noch
nie probiert habe den gibt es glaube ich
auch schon ein bisschen länger aber wenn
ich mir dann zum beispiel bei through
the kiwi oder mac florian brause habe
ich auch noch nie was von gehört erdberg
thies tasche oder hier dann sowas wie
diese milchshakes die auch neu sind also
natürlich kennt man diese milch shakes
erdbeer schoko und vanille
die gibt es ja überall aber jetzt gibt
es hier noch mac milchshake etwa
erdbeeren schreck schoko schoko vanille
karamell wer auch immer sich diese
doppelname ausgedacht hat hamburger
royal chili cheese cake den probiere ich
mal aus auch wenn ich eigentlich nicht
so gerne fleisch von dort essen oder
getränke gibt es auch noch aber das sehe
ich es als weniger interessant an also
wir haben ein paar sachen die ich
wirklich interessant findet ich schreibe
ich mir jetzt mal auf und bestelle die
komplett alle oder probieren wie die
einfach mal leider kann man so eine art
video nur gefühlt jedes jahr einmal
machen weil es gibt halt nicht genug
sachen die neue rauskommen und die dann
erst mal so von den leuten akzeptiert
werden müssen ich denke die meisten
sachen davon werden natürlich auch
wieder aus dem sortiment genommen ich
würde sagen wir fahren gleich los sehen
uns im auto
und ja bis gleich eine sache die ich
noch gefunden hat mc sunday anderen das
wusstest du dass es das gibt interessant
ich habe so viel was ich bin jetzt schon
ich bin autor vor da ich hoffe natürlich
dass ist dann immer dieses problem wenn
also sachen neu sind oder das sind
natürlich alles zusammen ich mal voraus
die die mehrheitlich kauft auf die dann
wirklich auch vor ort haben ich habe
schon auf die erfahrung gemacht dass es
dann halt nicht so war
aber ein paar sachen werden wir
sicherlich kriegen und dieser weg ist
hier zählt auf jeden fall meiner meinung
nach zu den
am besten also die haben eigentlich
immer alles mögliche was gerade im
angebot ist ich hätte gerne einen
veganen burger tl dazu eine hamburger
royal chili cheese bacon dazu ein mac
florian browser dazu ein mc sunday in
erdberg cream cheese moment und ein
entschuldigung noch ein eisklotz musik
für kiwis dazu prof kleine ich wollte
sagen wir mal irgendwas fehlt so ja dann
machen sie das
dankeschön dankeschön tag leute das ist
immer der gleiche verkäufer und da
überredet mich immer wieder für die
kinderhilfe zu spenden was natürlich
auch gut ist aber ich habe bei ihm
bestimmt schon fünfmal an die
kinderhilfe gespendet danke ach so dass
hier das war auch für mich
als andere
mc sunday mit ananas ach so ja okay
danke danke schön entschuldigung alle
für die lange schlange leute das hat so
lange gedauert hinter mir sind so viele
autos wahrscheinlich weil euro ist
wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich weil viele sachen die ich
jetzt halt bestellt habe auch nicht
unbedingt immer gemacht werden kann das
jetzt nicht verstehen und was ich noch
zur kindernothilfe sagen wollte ich habe
mich mal darüber informiert da kommen
alle spenden an das heißt es lohnt sich
ruhig auch mal eine 79 zu spät ich
könnte jetzt natürlich auch direkt nach
hause fahren aber das mache ich nicht
weil ich ein paar sachen im auto
probieren wollte einfach aus dem grund
weil die sonst gleich geschmolzen wie
zum beispiel dieses mclogo hause mit
erdbeer so sage ich euch der gamer in
der kamera so sieht es aus ich weiß
jetzt auch nicht ob das smarties drin
sind oder was das ist ich glaube mich
habe ich auf jeden fall vorher noch nie
gegessen und auch noch nie von gehört
ich würde gerne mal deine mutter kennen
werden diese kügelchen die hier drauf
sind es sind halt voll brause kugeln
also dubais drauf und ist kann einfach
nur browser oder ist für mich schon zur
pause aber sonst haben sich ganz lecker
wir haben hier direkt dieses max handeln
mit anderen so sehr hat das jetzt ja
sonst nur mit karamell schokolade und
erdbeer und jetzt auch mit anderen also
wirklich was ganz neues keine ahnung
warum man das jetzt ausgerechnet mit an
anders machen muss aber wir probieren es
einfach mal in diesem sirup hier sind
wirklich ananas stücke drin und da muss
ich sagen meiner meinung nach ist nicht
gut zusammen also also wir hatten jetzt
einmal das mit flori mit brause und das
max eine ananas und beide eis haben mich
echt ich überzeugt also hier würde ich
auch sagen fünf und zehn punkten und
diese als gemischt mit anderen stücken
was auch immer weiß ich nicht überzeugt
mich nicht aber das ist nur meine
meinung die haben wir jetzt noch ein
vanille karamell die finde ich extrem
geil aus den kann ich aber auch mit nach
hause nehmen und dann hier noch so ein
grünes getränk das war die wismut auf
jeden fall gesünder aus als der rest den
ich heute bekommen heute wieder zu hause
ich liebe diese kamera
vielleicht hast du so was schon mal
gesehen ist nicht alltäglich ist wieder
gesund
das ist das fans nie okay dann haben wir
als nächstes einen milchshake vanille
karamell max anders das habe ich schon
vor mir das gefällt mir jetzt nicht so
und mac os und diese beiden sachen muss
ich auf jeden fall noch probieren soll
auch diese beiden sachen aber wir haben
hier erstmal eine dann dies dass da noch
was allen nein jetzt habe ich die aus
dem deutschen mädchen aufgefallen ich
habe jetzt diese last becher aus dem
café vergessen wenn ihr sagt alex macht
dazu bekommen ein video dann gibt jetzt
mal nach oben weil da inzwischen auch
ein paar neue sachen der nase sie
keppler sie ist dass wir hier so einen
knick erdberg cream cheese tasche da ist
käse drin und interessanter hier steht
zwar noch mit veganen aber das ist der
trick bürger die veganen bürger zuerst
und ein normaler bürger musste ausleihen
und das steht einfach drauf 80 prozent
bleiben beim achtung
das hier ist der hamburger royal chili
cheese becker darf den optimieren
du kannst du hast du jetzt nicht mehr
sich das ist darauf nicht so leute jetzt
habe ich mal kurz die position getauscht
jetzt darfst du meinetwegen das alles
essen weil probier ganz schnell und dann
aber doch nix sagen okay
und jetzt genau genau ist eigentlich
ganz locker oder ich hatte irgendwie
angst es ein bisschen zu sein wird aber
ich finde eigentlich gut deutlich haben
wir jetzt den vanille karamell
milchshake der ist auch neu also einer
der drei neuen milchshake was sagst du
dazu lag vor allem am umzug kriegt man
so ein bisschen karamell doch mit
irgendwie 2 durch ich kann mich will die
nigerianer ist schon mal sehr leckere
milch getrunken habt nur das problem ist
der ganze strohhalm verstopft mit diesem
karamell zeugt so jetzt kannst du mit
den bürgern das sieht aus wie aus der
werbung machen bis jetzt langsam auf
naja gut der politik schon nach dass
jetzt der vegane bürger nicht so ich
gebe bisschen weiter weg
ich glaube ich habe den schon mal
probiert was sogar neben dem video views
und mitarbeiter entscheidet was wir
bekommen ist nicht gesehen hatte auf
jeden fall deutsche hier haben jetzt als
nächstes den hamburger royal chili
cheese bacon na dann bitte schön
der war so richtig gut aussah und direkt
so richtig franz irgendwie wenn wir
jetzt noch mal alles im blick haben was
würdest du hier für an punkte geben von
0 bis 10 66 für den veganen 9 und
hierfür dann ich würde hier für sieben
hierfür 8 und hierfür weiß ich nicht
weil ich habe noch nicht probiert und
der möglicher krieg auf jeden fall zehn
von zehn verliert bei ihr leute was ich
mir zum schluss aufgehoben hat und zwar
wie hier die cherry hieß sie noch mal
ich verließ den armen leute also erdbeer
cheesecake tasche das weiß ich
eigentlich gar nicht mag ist ich mag das
kann ja nur wenn man sich finde ich
schmecke jetzt genau das kommt dann sag
ich hab dich gar nicht verlässlich
trautwein krise auch so was zu trinken
mitgenommen
also leute das waren jetzt eine menge
neue produkte die ich so nicht kannte
ich denke mal die meisten von euch auch
nicht und ich hoffe dass wir dadurch
gefallen wenn ihr sagt machen es auf
jeden fall auch noch bei einem mccafé
weil das habe ich total vergessen ich
wollte es eigentlich alles in einem
video machen und jetzt nach oben wir
sehen uns morgen oder übermorgen wieder
da gibt's neues video haut rein
ja